de la délégation pour ce cette
thématique qui tient beaucoup à cœur à
la délégation et au Sénat celle des
communes nouvelles je rappelle si cela
était nécessaire mais je ne le crois pas
que vous avez été merde Annecy le Vieux
vous avez été adjoint au maire de la
commune nouvelle d'Annecy en Savoie et
vous avez été président de l'Assemblée
nationale alors Monsieur Jean-Marc vase
mère de terre de CO à fort joli nom
Seine-Maritime et
excellent département du mon collègue du
même département je ne ferai pas de
commentaires nous adorons tous les
départements monsieur et nous avons eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec vous lors des
rencontres sur les communes nouvelles
organisées par la MF souvent partenariat
avec le Sénat et naturellement je salue
avec beaucoup de plaisir Philippe
Chalopin qui met de Baugé en Anjou le
département on va dire
leader en résultat si je puis dire bien
qu'il y ait pas de compétition en
matière de comme une nouvelle et bouger
en Anjou ou se tiendra très
prochainement au mois d'août les
rencontres de la commune nouvelle
organisées par la Société des maires de
France alors je suis très heureuse de
saluer la présence aujourd'hui des
auditeurs de l'Institut du Sénat
l'Institut du Sénat est une institution
si je puis dire puisqu'elle mérite ce
nom qui a été qui a été créé à
l'initiative du Sénat je crois que
d'ailleurs c'est Jean les 11 du pont
notre prédécesseur qui était Président
et qui est encore président du
département du Calvados qui a eu cette
idée l'idée tant que le Sénat chacun le
sait
donne parfois l'impression mais ça n'est
qu'une qu'une impression d'être un
univers peut-être un peu secret
euh et peut-être confidentiel alors que
nous sommes d'une très grande
transparence
et d'une très grande clarté mais il
avait jugé
utile avait proposé au Président du
Sénat de créer cette institut pour
accueillir des auditeurs qui viennent
tout à la fois du monde de civil que du
monde des collectivités ou des
institutions pour que cette maison à
laquelle nous sommes tous très attachés
soit très ouverte mieux connu je crois
que c'est une une réussite on va vous
nous en parlerai je crois que je n'ai
jamais goût tout à l'heure et c'est
extrêmement important que le Sénat
participe de cette nécessité comment
dire d'une familiarité pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens avec les institutions
et le Sénat au-delà vous le savez de
cette institut accueille régulièrement
et chaque jour de nombreux visiteurs
au-delà des déplacements que nous
faisons donc merci à vous donc
aujourd'hui et je salue à leur
excusez-moi je veux va être maladroite
mais comme je suis dans les salutations
je salue la représentation de de la MF
qui est là avec nous donc aujourd'hui
nous ouvrons avec mon collègue
Eric et rouge une mission flash sur les
communes nouvelles dont nous
présenterons les conclusions le 28 juin
prochain le mercredi à nos collègues
avant les questions au Gouvernement là
vous savez chers amis que la délégation
aux collectivité qui s'intéressent à
tout ce qui concerne les collectivités
et leurs évolutions et leur
préoccupation suis avec beaucoup
d'intérêt
la thématique des communes nouvelles
parce que dans un océan de Carcans
administratif et législatif ou la loi
oblige plutôt les collectivités ou leur
interdit de prendre des initiatives la
commune nouvelle est une pépite de
liberté assez exceptionnelle puisque
c'est une initiative d'évolution qui est
à la main des élus locaux et aujourd'hui
entre les mains des seuls élus locaux
alors la commune nouvelle pour appeler
brièvement les choses elle est née en
2010 de la volonté du législateur de
conforter le fait communal une
conviction partagée par beaucoup que la
commune n'est pas le dernier maillon de
l'organisation de notre République mais
c'est plutôt le cœur du réacteur de
l'action publique et quand ceci
cette commune doit être confortée elle
doit prendre en compte les évolutions de
notre société les évolutions des
attentes de nos concitoyens et surtout
communal doit être un peu musclée et
conforté et donc en 2010 il y a eu cette
initiative qui était d'ailleurs aussi
porté par le président de l'Association
des maires de l'époque Jacques pélissa
c'est dire que un président de
l'association des maires qui participent
à la conception du fait de la commune
nouvelle montre que cette commune
nouvelle n'est en rédise pas ici des
communes mais au contraire la
consolidation de ce fait communal pour
garantir sa pérennité et son avenir en
il y a eu ici à la délégation un rapport
sur ce qui était encore une sorte de
curiosité un peu mal connue
rapport qui avait été conduit par mon
collègue Jacky mana Christian mana
pardon et moi-même mais que nous avions
appelé les communes nouvelles histoire
d'une révolution silencieuse parce que
on voyait que cette entreprise était
conduite d'une manière silencieuse par
les élus locaux mais qu'elle avait une
dimension révolutionnaire en ceci quelle
transformer considérablement
des territoires et qu'elle prouvaient la
capacité des élus locaux à prendre des
initiatives pour engager leur territoire
dans l'avenir mais aussi elle confirmait
leur capacité à assumer leur
responsabilité et donc nous avons ici en
septembre 2002 une rencontre parrainée
par
Gérard Larcher avec la messe que nous
avions appelé comme une nouvelle pour un
nouveau sous parce que le bilan montré
qu'après un élan
assez fort qui était dû il faut le dire
à une période de disette budgétaire de
la part de l'État et qui avait donc
encouragé des des élus à optimiser leurs
ressources en s'engageant dans des
communes nouvelles on constaté qu'il y
avait une sorte de pose sans doute qui
s'expliquait dans le fait qu'il y avait
une nouvelle mandature qui avait démarré
en 2020 que la période covid qui était
une période un peu particulière
n'encouragez pas forcément une facilité
pas la réflexion et la projection dans
l'amiante en tout cas pour certains le
verre était à moitié vide pour d'autres
à moitié plein en tout cas les faits
sont là il y a aujourd'hui quelques 800
comme une nouvelle qui regrouperait de
2600 communes quand même c'est le plus
fort mouvement d'évolution qu'il y a eu
largement supérieur à ce qu'on appelait
la loi Marcelin 1971 et nous sommes donc
aujourd'hui en dessous du seuil de 36000
même en dessous du seuil de de 35000 il
y a aujourd'hui
2.500000 personnes qui vivent dans des
communes nouvelles puisque c'est ce sont
2600 communes qui se sont regroupées en
commun une nouvelle donc aujourd'hui
nous nous intéressons à la manière
dont les communes nouvelles peuvent être
non pas inciter je fais très attention à
mes mots parce qu'il ne s'agit en aucun
cas pour nous d'être sur un objectif de
réduction des communes nous n'avons
aucun objectif
quantitative nous ne sommes pas des
agents de propagande forcenés sur la
commune nouvelle mais que nous pensons
dès lors que les conditions sont unies
que les élus le souhaitent cette
évolution d'une organisation qui
correspond souvent un périmètre de
bassin de vie est un moyen de pérenniser
d'une manière intelligente et positive
la la commune et que sans doute
aujourd'hui avec le désenchantement que
l'on constate de la part des élus il
faut rappeler que en 2020 sans ces
communes n'ont pas eu de candidats sans
doute que la commune nouvelle fait
partie de ces réponses possibles donc
nous aurons quelques questions et elles
sont de trois ordres c'est est-ce que la
commune nouvelle permet vraiment de
renforcer la capacité des territoires
alors que les communes historiques
étaient un peu petites ça les rapporter
plus de services aux habitants est-ce
que la commune nouvelle inscrit bien son
action dans un vrai projet territoire il
s'agit non simplement de
enfin de tracer de nouvelles frontières
mais quel est le projet quel avenir on
se dessine le troisième point qui est
très important c'est ce que les
mécanismes financiers ne sont pas
aujourd'hui plutôt décourageant et nous
travaillons beaucoup sur ce sujet et je
terminerai là et je laisserai la parole
à mon binôme
Eric kerouche qui présentera la
consultation en ligne que nous avons
lancée auprès des mers des comme une
nouvelle je vous remercie et je devrais
terminer en disant que nous avons
jusqu'à
10h30 ce qu'ensuite nous recevrons chers
collègues monsieur Guérini minisier
collectivité pour parler de la
tractivité
de la fonction
territoriale cher Éric merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente chère Françoise
merci beaucoup de ton introduction
messieurs les maires merci aussi de
votre présence aujourd'hui pour échanger
sur le sujet de la commune nouvelle
alors avant d'échanger sur celui-ci
simplement
appuyer le fait que vous le savez
Françoise Gatel est très impliqué sur ce
sur ce sujet et que nous avons vu avec
d'autres sénatrices et sénateurs que des
difficultés pouvaient voir le jour dans
le traitement dans le temps de la
situation des communes nouvelles d'où la
volonté de faire d'une certaine façon un
point d'étape et puis un tour d'horizon
sur la situation des communes nouvelles
et pour ce faire avec notamment mon
collègue Vincent Aubel nous avons
réfléchi à un petit un petit
questionnaire qui vous a été qui vous a
été soumis et ce questionnaire et je
vous en remercie à obtenir un taux de
réponse assez exceptionnel puisque nous
avons eu
280 répondants soit plus pratiquement
plus d'un tiers des communes nouvelles
et simplement vous dire que quand je
parle d'expérience en tant que chercheur
quand on doit ce genre de taux de
réponse dans une enquête cela signifie
d'abord que nous avons un très bon
échantillon présentatif ça c'est le
premier élément mais surtout la
mobilisation autour du questionnaire
elle traduit aussi une attente de elle
traduit aussi une attente de votre part
alors vous avez eu l'ensemble des
résultats la on a fait ici aujourd'hui
ce matin pour aller plus vite une petite
extraction pour que nous puissions aller
à l'essentiel et surtout vous entendre
après j'allais dire cette première
lecture de chiffres qui va s'avérer à la
fois limité contingente dans le temps
afin d'être efficace alors peut-être
commencer par le début sur la
morphologie de la commune nouvelle la
commune nouvelle c'est souvent
dans la première dans la première slide
donc
c'est souvent elle vient elle ne saurait
tarder
alors c'est toujours comme ça tout a été
répété et au moment de voilà je veux
dire ça je pense qu'on est tous on est
tous on est tous habitués à ça c'est
vraiment toujours la même chose ça a été
répété il y a pas eu de problème voilà
mais je veux dire non mais voilà ça
c'est tellement banal que
[Musique]
ceci étant en l'espèce pour la première
diapositive on n'a pas trop besoin
d'avoir la projection c'est quoi la
commune nouvelle c'est essentiellement
une commune qui en fait voilà en
regroupe en regroupe en regroupe 2 50 %
des plus de 50 % des communes nouvelles
rond on rejoint le chiffre global et la
distribution que l'on a par ailleurs
forcément puisque je vous l'ai dit
l'échantillon l'échantillon est très bon
et donc vous voyez que le rassemblement
de beaucoup de communes tout à droite
c'est-à-dire de si communes et plus et
relativement et relativement limité à un
peu plus de 13% de l'échantillon
simplement vous précisez aussi que la
commune nouvelle elle a une certaine
temporalité puisque 60% des communes
nouvelles ont été créées entre 2016 et
2017 et qu'ensuite il y en a eu 30 30%
pratiquement en 2019 donc on a une
morphologie particulière et une
temporalité
[Musique]
répartition assez large des des communes
nouvelles puisque dans l'échantillon qui
est le nôtre on a des communes comptant
128 habitants 150 habitants
dans la Haute-Loire dans l'un et on va
jusqu'à Annecy qui comporte 135 000
habitants donc d'une certaine façon on a
des différences de taille de commune
nouvelle qui sont aussi importantes que
les variations de taille des communes
tout court même si une grande partie des
communes nouvelles concentrent
une population
relativement relativement limité alors
après il y a la question de ça c'est
bien c'est la description mais la
question c'est celle du pourquoi
pourquoi on fait une commune nouvelle et
c'est la diapositive d'après on a
demandé on vous a demandé de de classer
les les raisons qui vous ont amené à
léchir à une commune nouvelle et en fait
on va dire on va le dire de façon
relativement simple la perspective qui
était la vôtre c'était de mutualiser et
de faire des économies d'échelle et vous
le voyez dans les différentes dans les
différents jugements alors on a vu une
échelle de 0 à 10 les moyennes les plus
importantes c'est la mutualisation c'est
les économies d'échelle et donc ces
économies d'échelle dont vous espériez
qu'elles allaient vous donner des
latitudes pour
faire développer de nouveaux services
publics d'une part et réaliser de
nouveaux projets d'autre part donc on a
vraiment une volonté de dynamisme de
faire plus avec le territoire qui était
et qui explique en grande partie
la décision qui a été la vôtre
ça c'est la décision qu'est-ce que ça a
amené dans les faits qu'elle a été le
bilan de la commune nouvelle en termes
de mutualisation et bien selon vous il
est largement positif et c'est ce que
montre la diapositive suivante puisque
en effet
72% des mers qui ont répondu à cette à
cette consultation estime que la commune
nouvelle a vraiment généré des économies
d'échelle
vous êtes également 90% 88% exactement à
affirmer que la commune nouvelle a
permis
d'émutualisations effectives aussi bien
en termes de service qu'en termes de
personnel et d'une certaine façon au vu
de ces chiffres peut-être
attendons-nous de vous aujourd'hui de
nous dire comment et selon quel modalité
la commune nouvelle a renforcé selon
vous ce pouvoir d'agir concrètement sur
les territoires et ce pouvoir d'agir
supplémentaire peut-être
permis par la commune nouvelle alors que
avant
les communes les juxtaposer les unes
avec les autres ne suffisait pas pour
permettre cette possibilité lors des
rencontres de de septembre
monsieur monsieur cholapin nous avait
dit que il y avait une prise de
conscience des habitants au moment d'un
incendie sur le fait que il fallait
renforcer la capacité d'action et que de
ce point de vue la commune nouvelle
avait été une solution peut-être
pourrait vous rebondir sur sur ce point
de vue
après se pose la la question de la de la
gouvernance
il y a moins de la moitié des mers qui
ont répondu qui estime que la commune
nouvelle a amené des difficultés de
gouvernance 45%
mais
dans le même temps vous dites que d'une
certaine façon la commune nouvelle n'a
pas été un enjeu de la campagne
électorale et surtout que
cette commune nouvelle a eu un impact en
termes d'organisation des services
municipaux dans le même temps la commune
nouvelle c'est pas le l'oubli des
territoires historiques puisque 68 68%
des répondants nous disent indique avoir
maintenu les communes déléguées donc une
volonté politique forte
la question de l'argent parce que
accessoirement ça peut nous concerner
ici et là dans les collectivités locales
c'est pas le sujet principal bien sûr
enfin néanmoins on peut s'y attarder
et la question était de savoir est-ce
que effectivement
la commune nouvelle a dégagé les moyens
et la réponse est oui parce que à
pratiquement 80%, vous nous avez dit que
les investissements nouveaux ont été
possibles grâce à la commune nouvelle
vous nous dites aussi que cette commune
nouvelle à 70% pratiquement cette
commune nouvelle a eu un impact positif
sur les dépenses de fonctionnement et
donc d'une certaine façon
les attentes que vous avez initiales
initialement dans la création elle se
sont retrouvées remplies dans le
jugement que vous portez
rétrospectivement sur les aspects
financiers de la commune de la commune
nouvelle quant à savoir si le
regroupement a
amener des pertes de tentation de
ressources de financement et bien vous
n'êtes que 20% à avoir cet avis ça veut
dire qu'il faut le voir à l'envers et
que effectivement le l'effet négatif n'a
pas été
aussi important il y a quand même des
effets de seuil que vous soulignez à 40%
et que
Françoise l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
un sujet majeur je rappelle juste un on
en a discuté notamment avec Cédric Vial
que la loi de finances 2023 a comporté
des éléments
correcteur on va dire que nous avons
porté collectivement au Sénat dans son
article de sang qui bon nous permettait
de dire que jusque les communes créées
après près de le 1er janvier 2022
bénéficierait d'une attribution au moins
égale à la somme des attributions
perçue par les communes l'année
précédente la création de la commune
nouvelle la perspective du Sénat allait
elle était toute simple
la présidente Françoise Gatel l'a dit
l'idée c'est pas d'aller dans une
dynamique de
forcenée de prosélytisme autour des
communes nouvelles mais d'accompagner
les choix positifs qui ont été faits par
les territoires et bien entendu
on ne peut pas avoir des entre
guillemets des désincitations à la
création de communes nouvelles parce que
les financements de celle-ci ne seraient
pas
facilité en tout cas au-delà de ça vous
soulignez les effets positifs des marges
de manœuvre financière que vous avez
retrouvé et puis il faut finir surtout
par la dernière diapositive qui est
peut-être la plus la plus importante
parce que la question elle était toute
simple au final est-ce que vous referiez
les choses au final est-ce que
l'expérience a été positive
et bien là la réponse qui est la vôtre
est relativement claire
c'est que oui c'est cette diapositive
donc
si c'était parfait est-ce que vous vous
relanceriez dans la création d'une
commune nouvelle oui tout à fait 65 %,
oui plutôt
18%. donc vous voyez bien que là on a un
jugement très très positif et puis il y
a l'aspect refaire mais il y a l'aspect
c'est quoi la photo actuellement et il
s'avère que vous jugez que pratiquement
90% que votre commune nouvelle
fonctionne de manière positive avec
un aspect très bon à 40% et plutôt bon à
47%. donc d'une certaine façon et parce
que je vais un territoire de rugby vous
dire que la commune nouvelle en ce qui
vous concerne dans les réponses à
transformer l'essai et que pour marquer
un essai bien entendu c'est un effort
collectif et qui fait parfois du mal et
il n'y a pas que des aspects positifs
même si ceci domine largement et
maintenant
avec la présidente Gatel nous attendons
vos réactions non seulement à ce
questionnaire mais également aux
questions qu'elle a pu poser
initialement je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Eric merci de votre
compréhension comme vous l'avez vu nous
avons un problème de rythme dans
l'arrivée des
des diapos elle n'arriveront peut-être
pas tout avant la fin de cette réunion
mais c'est à l'insuline si je suis parce
que en fait c'est très performant parce
que c'est un peu sophistiqué donc quand
ça n'est plus performant ça pose un
problème on doit être relié à la Régie
qu'elle même un problème voilà donc
pardonnez-nous
donc on vous transmettra naturellement
très rapidement les éléments sur papier
si c'est possible maintenant en tout cas
vous les aurez merci de votre indulgence
donc et je voulais juste avant de passer
la parole peut-être à Monsieur
accueillez dire un mot sur ce rouge a
dit qui est très important
au Sénat lors du projet de loi de
finance et vraiment une
alors sans doute que dans ta région de
rugby moi qui suis bretonne on le
pratiquement mais on parle d'impact
voilà et que il y a eu un pack
sénatorial pour prêter beaucoup
d'attention à l'impact budgétaire
parfois négative d'une manière un peu
forte des lois de finances successives
qui donnaient des résultats
imprévisibles inattendus non annoncé
pour ceux qui avaient fait des communes
nouvelles et nous avons donc tous porté
les différents groupes du du Sénat les
républicains les centrises les
socialistes les communistes et même les
radicaux je crois nous avons porté le
même amendement pour qu'il y ait sur la
loi de finances 2023 à maintien de la
dotation et un engagement
à creuser la question de la commune
nouvelle et voir comment on ne pouvait
pas en tout cas
continuer à voir des aventures sens
positifs et des tentative de commune
nouvelle qui se retrouve
pénalisés qu'en tout cas là où des
territoires voudraient s'engager
aujourd'hui dans des communes nouvelles
pour des raisons X ou Y les voix
hésitées reculées parce qu'à un moment
il y a une sorte de punition enfin on
appelle ça comme ça une punition
financière qui n'est incompréhensible
voilà je serai pas plus longue donc je
propose que nous démarrions par vous
monsieur à quoi il est que vous nous
parliez
d'Annecy Jean-Marc va nous parlera un
peu de son expérience
normande et Philippe Chalopin et donc si
nous pouvons garder naturellement un
temps
pour les questions qui seront sans doute
nombreuses je vous remercie donc
monsieur Accoyer pour nos collègues qui
nous ont rejoints est en visio depuis
Annecy je vous je vous je vous salue et
on est heureux de de penser à Annecy
voilà donc je vous passe la parole
nous avons un problème de son
monsieur à quoi vous pouvez lui envoyer
un message
oui
alors on avait le droit à deux petites
choses qui fonctionnaient pas là on les
atteint
son micro est un
oui vous pouvez lui envoyer un message
donc je bon sinon moi je propose
monsieur Vasse peut-être pour pas perdre
de temps et vous pouvez expliquer
monsieur aquailler voilà Jean-Marc
j'arrive pas est-ce que vous m'entendez
là ah bon alors pardon Jean-Marc merci
Monsieur parfait merci
et bien
vous m'entendez très bien
aimable que vous avez eu à l'égard à
l'égard du territoire d'Annecy
merci pour votre invitation qui me
replonge dans une enceinte parlementaire
et en particulier l'enceinte
prestigieuse du Sénat dont on a rarement
vu à quel point sa présence dans nos
institutions le BIC amerisme était
important comme il l'être aujourd'hui
nous le mesurons chaque jour bravo pour
ce travail qui lui aussi
évoque une des méthodes de travail du
Sénat c'est à dire l'évaluation de ce
qui a été imaginé concrétisé
c'est-à-dire les fusions de communes je
serai assez rapide avec peut-être en
préalable une remarque qui
concerne l'excellente exposée
qui est rouge et qui me paraît de voir
distinguer la masse importante des
communes de taille petite moyenne en
termes de population par rapport à des
communes plus importantes soit chacune
des communes fusionnées soit par la
nouvelle et autant pour des petites
communes
l'intérêt de la fusion est multiple et
évident
d'abord parce que l'évolution
démographique la diminution des services
publics les coûts
des de ses services les recettes des
collectivités tout convergent vers
l'intérêt de travailler dans cette
direction et vous l'avez madame la
Présidente bien expliqué
sur pour les les fusions de communes
beaucoup plus importante et à Annecy
nous avons abouti à une commune nouvelle
qui aujourd'hui doit pas être loin de
150 000 habitants compte tenu de la
démographie extrêmement tactile de notre
territoire
la question paraît différente en réalité
cette décision de fusion qui a été
retenue par six communes
cinq tours d'Annecy plus sensibles bien
sûr
avait
des motivations qui étaient
simples et vous les avez évoqué tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs dans le sondage
c'est-à-dire réaliser des économies
d'échelle
réaliser la mise en commun des
ressources humaines du patrimoine
immobilier et
du patrimoine matériel
le tout aurait dû
aboutir à une diminution
des charges globales et de meilleures
performances financières tout en
maintenant la même qualité des services
publics et forcer le constater que
maintenant six ans après la fusion
puisque celle-ci est intervenue au 1er
janvier 2017 et bien
aucune de ces deux aucun de ces deux
objectifs n'ont été remplis alors il
faut être positif parce que je pense
qu'ils auraient pu être remplis la
commune d'Annecy-le-Vieux dont j'étais
pendant 28 ans mère avant la fusion
avec comme objectif d'apporter un
meilleur service sans augmenter la
fiscalité et en bénéficiant d'une
restriction en quelque sorte d'une
diminution de la charge portée par
toutes les toutes les par tous ces
communes et par leur contribua bles
telle n'a pas été le cas parce que
certes l'étude d'impact était
probablement insuffisante sur les
conséquences de la fusion mais surtout
que ceci n'avait pas été suffisamment et
inscrit dans dans le pacte de fusion et
il me semble que pour ses grandes
fusions de communes il faudrait inscrire
dans le barbe des objectifs avec un
suivi de ces objectifs c'est à dire
l'évolution chaque année une évaluation
annuelle et le Sénat chez bien faire les
évaluations
du devenir déséfectifs territoriaux du
patrimoine et immobilier avec bien
entendu une session de ce qui devient
inutile ou une mise en location enfin
bref une réduction de la charge est-elle
n'a pas été le cas et le service public
n'a pas été amélioré les habitants
s'auto contraires déroutées par les
changements d'adresse de ces services
une certaine forme de dilution de
qui doit y avoir entre le moment de la
question et du retour de la presse ou
bien de la demande d'un service et de
l'arrivée de ce service et donc
globalement je pense pour les grandes
communes qu'il y aurait à travailler
pour les grandes fusions ou les fusions
de communes numériquesment importantes
en nombre d'habitants il faudrait qu'il
y ait un cahier des charges contraignant
et que ce cahier des charges
contraignant soit imposés pendant au
moins un mandat de la même façon que que
vous madame Gatel avait eu la bonne idée
d'élargir le nombre de conseillers
municipaux de la commune nouvelle
pendant un mandat il faudrait qu'il y
ait une disposition au moins pendant un
mandat 6 ans qui oblige à concrétiser
les raisons qui ont conduit l'ensemble
de ces conseils municipaux à aboutir à
la fusion voilà ce que je pourrais vous
dire de façon extrêmement synthétique
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas récupérer
de la même façon les communes qui sont
avec un nombre d'habitants relativement
faible et des services publics à cette
échelle et parfois devenu impossible à
rendre un épuisement des élus ou même
des candidatures et puis des communes
plus importantes ou au contraire il y a
de nombreux services de proximité qui
ont été instaurées des fonctionnaires de
qualité qui ont été recrutés dans les
différentes collectivités dont le
rapprochement n'est pas toujours son
problème même si on le voit dans votre
sondage ça crée des opportunités pour le
déroulement des carrières dans la
fonction publique territoriale mais ça
n'est pas l'objectif l'objectif c'est le
contribuable c'est le citoyen c'est la
collectivité et c'est l'intérêt général
et donc je vous invite madame Gatel dans
votre inventivité fructueuse et utile
pour le pays à travailler dans ce
nuancement entre l'importance des
différentes communes et je vous remercie
peut avoir fait revenir dans un domaine
que j'ai abandonné il y a quelques
années pour me consacrer désormais à
l'énergie et à la catastrophe de notre
patrimoine énergétique lié comme la
commission d'enquête parlementaire la
bien montré un déserts n'aurait
probablement pas commises car il est le
spécial des études d'impact et de
l'évaluation je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président je ne sais pas si
vous pouvez voir
on va dire les les sourires extrêmement
positifs de satisfaction de tous mes
collègues
en écho à vos propos sur le Sénat nous
nous efforçons d'être à la hauteur jour
après jour Monsieur le Président en tout
cas vraiment merci merci beaucoup de
votre analyse qui est très juste deux
points avant de passer la parole à
Jean-Marc va c'est l'étude d'impact
préalable extrêmement importante vous
l'avez évoqué tellement importante
parfois
sous-estimé dans la période précédente
parce que il y avait une accélération du
calendrier qui faisait qu'il y avait une
marche forcée si importante que nous
l'avons inscrite dans la loi
effectivement le projet le pacte de
fusion qui doit être comme vous le dites
qui doit faire l'objet d'un indicateur
et qui doit être mesuré dont le
déroulement se fait dans un temps qui
n'est pas parfois pas celui qu'on
envisageait initialement parce qu'il au
départ des surcos mais on doit s'assurer
que l'objectif est atteint notamment en
termes d'efficacité de l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier habitant dans des temps
acceptables vous savez très bien résumé
l'objectif merci en tout cas de notre
échange et je suis sûr que il y aura des
questions de la part de mes collègues
donc si vous voulez bien nous partons en
Normandie
cher Jean-Marc va Monsieur le Maire de
terre au pluriel de Co
vous avez la parole merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le vice-président et
Monsieur les sédateurs sédatrices et
Cher Pascal chers Sonia retrouve des
Normands Jean-Marc va subir de terre de
cours en Normandie en Seine-Maritime au
cœur du pays de Caux et
je suis un vieux maire puisque j'ai été
élu conseiller municipal en 89 et mère
en 1994 du bourg de Fauville-en-Caux à
20 km de Fécamp
et c'est gentil à vous puisque
finalement c'est effectivement après 20
années d'expérience et alors que la loi
RCT 2010 était sortie que j'ai demandé
au collègues de réfléchir à cette
opportunité qui se présentait de se dire
alors que nous étions 21 21 communes
regroupées dans une comcom rurale de
moins de 9000 habitants avec Fauville
pour bourg et au temps de villages
alentours le bourg faisant 2200
habitants
l'expérience acquise
m'amenait à dire que nous devions
nous devions être en mesure de faire
mieux et davantage
au regard des divisions que l'on pouvait
constater et peut-être aussi parce que
la communauté de communes dans son
intercommunalité qu'un cas essayait de
faire ce qui lui était dévolue par le
jeu des transferts de compétences ce
transfert des compétences qui fait qu'on
amuse les compétences de la ville centre
au profit de l'intercommunalité et
il me semblait qu'on pouvait faire
davantage et faire mieux donc c'est ce
que j'ai proposé aux collègues de
réfléchir à la constitution d'une
commune nouvelle et puis la loi notre
arrivée
et du coup ça devenait un enjeu d'autant
plus important puisque la question du
seuil des communes des intercommunités
n'étaient pas encore fixés et mais à
moins de 10000 on le sentait mal et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
réfléchi à l'échelle avec la présidente
de la comcom qui était maire d'un
village alentours nous avons réfléchi à
associer tout le monde pour en quelque
sorte transformer les séries
sauf qu'il nous fallait obtenir
l'unanimité à 21
et que les maires n'ont pas été en
capacité d'obtenir c'est uneanimité
alors j'ai repris mon bâton de pèlerins
en tant que mère de du chef-lieu et j'ai
proposé à ceux qui le voulaient bien de
de s'associer dans une démarche de
constituer une commune nouvelle Limbourg
et six autres collègues se sont associés
donc d'Imbours et de six villages
alentours et nous sommes partis à 7 et
nous sommes arrivés à 7 et c'était déjà
un premier succès
le sujet principal c'est de se dire
en fait le bourg il sert à tout le monde
il n'appartient pas qu'au Villet il
appartient à tous ceux qui le
fréquentent à tous ceux qui travaillent
à tous ceux qui le visitent et donc il y
avait cette espèce de sentiment
d'appartenance
et de faire comprendre aussi
au Conseil municipaux du bout et aussi
aux habitants que le bourré avait cette
vitalité cette médecin de cabinet
d'infirmière des commerces et services
publics etc donc plutôt satisfaisant
mais on le devait aussi au village
alentours et que donc nous avions à
faire cause commune et c'est comme ça
que nous avons pensé nécessaire de
constituer cette commune nouvelle
avec un enjeu qui a tout de suite fédéré
parce que peut-être que la première des
compétences de la commune nous parle
au-delà de ces missions et galliennes au
nom de l'État la première compétence de
la commune c'est d'abord l'école et que
du coup ça nous permettait aussi de
mobiliser pour une école rénovée et nous
sommes ateliers à ce chantier là que
Pascal Martin viendra bientôt inauguré
puisqu'on avait eu aussi le soutien du
Département qui présidait à l'époque
mais
il y avait aussi un autre projet
qui n'aurait jamais pu voir le jour si
nous n'avions pas eu cette capacité à
être ensemble c'est la revitalisation
des activités commerciales de service
et plus largement des activités
économiques du bourg et
PVD est arrivé il y avait vous le savez
à une tour mardi et PVD finalement est
venu en quelque sorte comme
petite ville de demain le programme de
la NCT
et c'est finalement PVD est venu en
quelque sorte donner une espèce de label
se dire oui nous avons intérêt à
travailler dans à la revitalisation du
bourg pour continuer à être actif alors
le nombre d'habitants continue de
croître nous avons une demande
d'installation parce que nous sommes à
la confluence de deux zones d'emploi
de deux zones d'emploi forte et puis la
loi neutre nous a amené j'en termine
là-dessus nous a amené à
embrasser une grande interco XXL
une grande intercommunalité XXL et avec
d'autres enjeux et notamment des enjeux
de richesse fiscale voilà peut-être
voilà peut-être madame la Présidente
Monsieur vice-président mais président
excusez-moi de mais je oui monsieur le
Président accueillez nous vous entendons
encore très bien
[Rires]
merci merci
bon
Jean-Marc si tu me comprends merci
alors peut-être pour terminer deux
observations
on a parlé de taille et d'échelle
et à chaque fois qu'on parle de taille
Eric le disait tout à l'heure on parle
de taille en nombre d'habitants
je crois que une des caractéristiques et
l'enquête le montre c'est que les
communes nouvelles généralement se font
sur des territoires ruraux et la taille
elle s'apprécie aussi en termes de
superficie et c'est un enjeu essentiel
dans nos réflexions me semble-t-il
il faut il faut croiser pour avoir deux
facteurs un facteur sur le nombre
d'habitants et en quelque sorte c'est la
densité finalement qui est derrière qui
est deuxièmement celui de l'échelle
alors on parle toujours d'économie
d'échelle
je crois que l'échelle ça nous permet
aussi de prendre de la hauteur et du
coup ça nous permet de repousser en
quelque sorte les frontières et
justement mardi Jean-Marc Hofner disait
quelque chose de très très juste en
disant finalement quand on constitue des
collectivités on trace des frontières
et la frontière c'est ce qui permet à ne
pas parler à son voisin d'ailleurs on a
on a inventé l'intercommunité pour ça
pour pouvoir parler ensemble et je
voudrais livrer cet réflexion que parce
que j'ai trouvé ça juste quand on a
constitué la commune nouvelle entre ce
qui se passait avant dans le dialogue au
sein de l'interpro à 21 et ce qui s'est
passé après avec la commune nouvelle on
s'est mis à parler davantage parce que
nous étions tous autour de la table nous
7 et on en a oublié des autres le
pourtour on a repoussé effectivement la
frontière on a éliminé les frontières
intérieures bien évidemment il faudra y
revenir d'ailleurs sur les frontières
intérieures des communes déléguées mais
pour être effectivement faire cause
commune en un
et j'ai souvent l'habitude de dire que
de mon point de vue et peut-être c'est
ce que je pense auprès de la MF en ma
qualité de mes référents pour
l'accompagnement des communes nouvelles
aux côtés de Philippe Chalopin de mon
point de vue une commune nouvelle est
une commune singulière et pluriel et les
singulièrement pluriel parce que nous
devons à la fois l'apprécier dans sa
capacité à être une mais également dans
sa pluralité si on oublie cela sur les
communes nouvelles constituées d'un plus
grand nombre de communes et on voit bien
que dans l'enquête
mais cette caractéristique est
importante et Philippe charlepin pourra
compléter puisque il a cette expérience
d'avoir fait deux fois là d'avoir
repoussé deux fois la frontière et donc
d'avoir augmenté la pluralité merci de
votre attention
concernant la particularité si je puis
dire
de la démarche des communes nouvelles en
Normandie c'est le calendrier
vous l'avez bien dit Monsieur le Maire
on a vu une accélération de la création
de comme une nouvelle je l'ai dit dans
une période où il y avait une dizaine
budgétaire et deuxièmement en lien avec
la loi notre où il y a eu un moment
parfois encouragé on va dire par les
autorités de l'État local la
constitution de très grandes intercos
refuser que des petites communes ne
trouvaient plus leur place ou que la
grande interco ne reprenait pas des
compétences exercées précédemment par la
petite
la petite communauté de communes et des
collègues ici pour en témoigner et donc
il y a une constitution commune nouvelle
ça c'est le premier point et on a depuis
travailler sur l'idée de commune
communauté on en dira peut-être un mot
je ne sais pas et je retiens deux mots
la communauté la commune nouvelle elle
est singulière et pluriel c'est une
commune nouvelle de 5 ou 10 000
habitants ne sera jamais le double
parfait d'une commune historique de
cette taille parce que vous gardez
plusieurs clochers vous gardez plusieurs
églises et vous gardez un territoire
extrêmement vaste et c'est bien et je
regarde notamment Cédric Vial avec qui
on travaille beaucoup sur le sur le
sujet comme avec Eric et d'autres
collègues
Pascal Martin ou Agnès canaillé
on a bien cette idée d'une particularité
d'une singularité qu'il va falloir qu'on
qu'on entende donc nous allons glisser
si je puis dire vers l'Anjou
Monsieur le Maire de Baugé en Anjou qui
en fait
donc à procéder une première création de
communes nouvelles il a en quelque sorte
redoublé l'exercice mais d'une manière
positive ce qu'il avait réussi
voilà Monsieur le Maire de Baugé cher
Philippe vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente merci de nous
accueillir monsieur le vice-président
pour cette présentation complète
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ça
aille beaucoup de plaisir que
j'interviens devant cette auditoire de
qualité et avec lequel nous entretenons
des relations très très régulières je
suis donc Philippe Chopin maire de Baugé
en Anjou
je suis aussi président de l'Association
Départementale des maires de
Maine-et-Loire et président de la côté
de commune bourgeois vallée
qui aurait pu regrouper 38 communes et
qui ne regroupent que 7 puisque il y a
cinq communes nouvelles parmi les 7
Baugé en Anjou a été créé en mars 2012
avec un vote à 82 ou 3% des conseillers
de 5 conseils municipaux
et élargit en juillet 2015 où là nous
avons intégré l'intégralité des communes
de la Communauté de Communes et nous
avons donc vécu pendant un an sans
communauté de communes en étant une
commune communauté par anticipation
à l'orientation de la loi
cette communauté dans l'Anjou donc
l'Anjou c'était
383 communes c'est maintenant 177
communes c'est à l'est c'est 263
km², 26000 hectares 45 habitants au
kilomètre carré ce que dit Jean-Marc est
tout à fait juste la commune nouvelle
elle s'apprécie pas forcément avec le
nombre d'habitants elle s'apprécie aussi
par rapport à la superficie par rapport
à la densité c'est un sujet c'est les
problèmes de mobilité c'est les
problèmes d'accès au service public
c'est les problèmes d'accès aux soins
enfin tout ce qu'on peut retrouver
dans cette situation notre commune
a été labellisé j'en suis assez fier RSO
responsabilité sociétale les
organisations à l'échelle de nos 15
communes déléguées
nous avons décidé de nous regrouper pour
continuer à exister en fait parce que
l'enjeu il était là et si notre
regroupement ne s'était pas fait nous
aurions perdu des habitants nous aurions
perdu tous nos services si Jean-Marc a
forcément juste dit justement que la
commune nouvelle c'est une commune
spécifique head maire d'une commune
nouvelle j'étais mère en 2008 je suis
maire d'une commune nouvelle c'est une
dimension un petit peu différente quand
même une écoute une projection sur le
territoire qui n'a rien à voir moi je
suis le maire des 15 communes déléguées
nous avons gardé nos 15 communes
déléguées avec nos 15 mères délégués je
dirais sur ce point c'est c'est un choix
mais en tout cas je suis persuadé pour
reprendre les démos qui ont été dit que
la commune nouvelle c'est effectivement
c'est faire mieux
et faire plus
avec plus on ne sait pas toujours parce
que c'est un c'est un enjeu qui est
important en tout cas c'est c'est faire
plus pour nos habitants on a fait un
sondage à l'égard des habitants pour
leur demander ce que représentait pour
eux la commune nouvelle ce que ça
signifie la commune nouvelle c'est plus
de service donc on estimait avoir rempli
notre objectif alors notre commune
nouvelle nous c'est 26000 hectares
240 bâtiments à gérer 240 bâtiments 15
églises 11 écoles
282 associations un taux de chômage qui
a diminué depuis qu'on est passé en
commune nouvelle parce que on est le
territoire est certainement plus
attractif on peut offrir des services
aux entreprises qu'on ne pouvait pas
offrir c'est une maison de santé là où
la santé est un vrai sujet on s'est
constitué pour une construire ensemble
une maison de santé c'est 60
professionnels aujourd'hui c'est notre
territoire alors peut-être que ça fait
exception mais on n'a pas de difficulté
effectivement de recrutement de médecins
que on a pu mettre en face des éléments
c'est aussi on nous dit il faut que les
services publics soient moins de 20
minutes nous ils sont à moins de 10
minutes et dans quelques jours ils
seront à moins de 5 minutes puisque dans
chaque mairie déléguée on va mettre un
point d'accès numérique qui permettra
aussi citoyens d'anticiper les démarches
auprès de la Maison en France service
qu'on a bien évidemment créé notre
commune ça a été aussi une mutualisation
importante et on peut mettre des
chiffres je alors on fait pas on fait
pas de communes nouvelles sans projet de
territoire
c'est pas la peine faut pas une commune
nouvelle pour gagner de l'argent on fait
une commune nouvelle pour mutualiser et
nous on a fait des économies on a arrêté
de regarder mais pendant très longtemps
on faisait entre 400 et 500000 euros
d'économies par an sur notre budget
charge générale
en comparant à charge constante bien
évidemment parce que la commune nouvelle
c'est là où il y a un enjeu c'est que
les habitants se l'approprient et puis
demandent de plus en plus de services
j'avais pas de police municipale
aujourd'hui j'ai une police municipale
on n'avait pas d'éducateur on a
maintenant des éducateurs pour nos
enfants donc les frais de personnels
n'ont pas explosé contrairement à ce que
j'entends parfois il faut les maîtriser
il faut regarder bien évidemment
nunérations qui sont inférieures au
ratio d'une commune de notre strat si on
peut si on peut comparer on est à peine
à 50%.
la commune nouvelle et vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le vice-président elle nous a
permis de faire face à des événements
majeurs la pandémie
on a pu grâce à notre CCAS à l'échelle
du territoire aller au contact de chaque
habitant les mers délégués étaient des
relais de chaque habitant pour faire
remonter les difficultés on met en place
des systèmes de transport et puis aussi
durant l'incendie la ville de Beaujeu en
Anjou a été impactée par un grand
incendie cet été 1300 hectares ont été
ravagés et bien on a plus mobilisé à
l'échelle de notre territoire et en
quelques semaines on a remis en état des
chemins pour permettre aux propriétaires
de sortir le bois qui avait été brûlé
durant cette incendie donc moi je dis
alors peut-être que on dira je suis pas
objectif mais la commune nouvelle c'est
effectivement plus de services c'est une
plus grande réactivité c'est c'est aussi
c'est sauver la commune parce que nous
sommes tous des fervents partisans de la
commune
mais ces communes elles ont évolué elles
étaient des paroisses il y a quelques
siècles elles se sont transformées en
communes et aujourd'hui la commune
nouvelle nous permet de garder du
service dans des territoires laisse du
département je vous invite à venir le 29
juin non pas le 29 août madame
présidente le 29 juin et oui alors je
sais le 29 juin venir donc à la
rencontre des communes nouvelles et vous
verrez que notre commune elle vit bien
il y a peut-être des soucis comme il y a
des soucis dans des communes
traditionnelles bien évidemment ça ne
change rien on est obligé d'être plus
dans la proximité peut-être que dans
certains cas mais en tout cas notre
commune aujourd'hui les habitants se loi
sont appropriés mais il faut du temps
2012 2023 l'arrêté du 1er janvier 2013
arrêtez du préfet la commune ça se crée
pas avec des panneaux et un arrêté
préfectoral la commune ça se crée avec
des hommes c'est une addition d'hommes
et de femmes de compétences qui le
propri petit à petit la commune les
associations cela pourrit il faut
simplement un peu de temps on va fêter
nos 10 ans et aujourd'hui si c'était à
refaire on a posé la question aux
habitants il faudrait le refaire et
pourtant on les a pas consultés comme on
l'entend avec un référendum parce que à
un moment donné il y a un lien de
confiance qui se crée avec les élus et
en fait aujourd'hui les élus et le
suffrage nous a donné raison puisque
nous avons été réélus avec notre liste
régulièrement depuis la création de la
commune nouvelle donc c'est vraiment le
message que je veux faire passer et puis
après on aura quelques sujets notamment
les finances parce qu'il faut pas
sanctionner un moment donné les ce que
c'est de faire des efforts et de trouver
des solutions merci de votre attention
si avant de passer la parole à
Eric deux points intéressants sur
l'expérience de bouger en Anjou et merci
d'avoir corrigé mon erreur sur la latte
c'est la notion d'espace et de densité
c'est extrêmement important de se dire
que la commune nouvelle elle consolide
elle ne rapproche pas forcément
physiquement les gens des services et en
tout cas quand vous avez cité le nombre
d'églises le nombre de bâtiments publics
ça montre les choses donc c'est
important qu'on prenne en compte cette
dimension et puis vous avez beaucoup
parlé des communes déléguées et du
maintien des communes déléguées et on
voit bien qu'autour de ce sujet il y a
des questions et des approches
différentes mais je pense que c'est une
question extrêmement
importante et vous ai parlé du temps il
faut effectivement du temps moi je
prends souvent l'image d'une famille
recomposée quand vous êtes une famille
recomposée chacun a son histoire et un
moment vous devez construire un commun
et vous transformez la commune nouvelle
c'est un peu ça il faut du temps il faut
beaucoup le précédent président de la
commission des lois le disait
d'affection sociétale c'est-à-dire
la commune nouvelle ne peut pas être un
périmètre totalement artificiel
est cousu juste pour bénéficier
d'optimisation de quelques natures il y
a une histoire en commun ou en tout cas
une identité comme une à partager je ne
serai pas plus long cher Eric puis après
chers collègues nous prenons les
questions
merci d'abord
merci d'avoir pour ces pour ces
témoignages juste reprendre vraiment
très vite trois points que vous avez que
vous avez souligné la question de la
densité et la question des la question
des périmètres
Jean-Marc a parlé de du fait qu'on avait
repoussé d'une certaine façon avec la
commune la capacité de la capacité de
coopération c'est à dire qu'elle est
plus forte à l'intérieur de de la
commune nouvelle mais que le risque
c'est de mettre à l'écart aussi les
autres c'est un problème global de nos
collectivités territoriales on réfléchi
dans nos périmètres et d'une certaine
façon la commune nouvelle a grandi un
périmètre mais on a aussi la question de
la coopération avec les tâches supérieur
voire entre voir entre commune et bien
entendu c'est lié
au rapport à l'espace qui est un
problème majeur j'allais dire pour
l'ensemble de nos collectivités on parle
pas de la même façon selon qu'on est
dans un territoire dense ou dans un
territoire qu'on qualifie pudiquement de
peu danse et c'est pas les mêmes
logiques de c'est pas les mêmes logiques
de service ce qui est important aussi et
ce que vous avez mis en
vraiment souligné tous les deux c'est la
question du maillage la question de la
spécificité
de la communauté du maillage particulier
qu'elle permet qu'on ne retrouve pas
forcément justement dans les communes et
je pense que c'est une qualité en termes
de en termes de proximité et en ce sens
ça peut être une inspiration et le
dernier point pour finir parce que je
pense qu'on y est tous sensible c'est la
question des financements et je crois
qu'il faut être assez clair là-dessus
on ne peut pas sanctionner ceux qui ont
fait des efforts en tout cas il ne faut
pas sanctionner ou aller à rebrousse à
rebrousse poil de ceux qui ont fait de
ceux qui ont fait des efforts et là on
serait complètement à contretemps parce
que en fait je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
il faut pas qu'on soit sans être dans le
prosélytisme encore qu'on doit
accompagner les communes nouvelles il ne
faut pas qu'on se place dans des
logiques des incitatives et c'est à nous
d'y veiller collectivement
merci beaucoup si l'effort ne les formes
ne doit pas donner lieu à punition c'est
exactement ça alors nous avons deux
souhaits de parole
indiqué en tout cas Sonia de la propreté
et Charles
Guinée merci à vous deux je propose
qu'on regroupe ces deux questions et que
vous organisez votre réponse puis
ensuite on prendra une autre vague
oui merci madame le Président
ma première question
puisque vous êtes vraiment au sein d'un
travail qui qui met ensemble plusieurs
parcours trajectoires de communes
nouvelles est-ce que parce que
évidemment on entend un propos très
positif de votre part enfin assez
positif
il n'empêche que la commune nouvelle
dite la nouvelle commune par la ministre
Jacqueline gros à l'époque c'est trois
communes rurales regroupées moins de
1500 habitants c'est une ancienne
intercommunalité avec 24 communes
historiques qui deviennent comme une
nouvelle et c'est parfois huit communes
qui sont sur un territoire
particulièrement logique était
d'ailleurs souvent celle du syndicat
scolaire celui du syndicat scolaire et
on est vraiment dans un dans un
territoire de vie est-ce que dans vos
retours vous échanges vous avez des
éléments qui qui vous alertent soit sur
une taille critique soit sur le fait que
dans cette fameuse nouvelle commune
c'est tellement que finalement il y a
aussi les ferments de de si ce n'est
d'échec en tout cas de moins bon
fonctionnement et est-ce que vous avez
des témoignages quand même de volonté de
retour en arrière sur les constitutions
de communes nouvelles parce que on a eu
un renouvellement électoral
c'est souvent souvent pas toujours pas
le maire qui a constitué la commune
nouvelle qui a été élue et donc il n'est
pas forcément proactif dans la
Constitution qui ne l'a pas été et donc
est-ce que vous vous sentez qu'il y a
quand même un moment de de frottement et
de retour en arrière ma deuxième
question porte sur l'urbanisme et les
documents d'urbanisme comment avez-vous
réalisé vos documents d'urbanisme parce
que vous avez constitué des PLU voir
maintenant on est dans la phase pluie
pour un pour un certain nombre pas tout
le monde
avec des documents d'urbanistes très
hétérogènes avec encore des cartes
communales pour certains certaines
communes où en êtes-vous est-ce que ça a
été une difficulté pour vous à cette
question d'urbanisme et et question
corollaire s'applique dans des communes
qui n'ont pas de continuité urbaine
puisque c'est la commune nouvelle tout
un tas de réglementations et
d'obligations en matière d'aménagement
du territoire je pense à la loi SRU mais
il y en a bien d'autres le
un sujet également
et comment comment gérez-vous cette
question je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente
tout d'abord je remercie nos
intervenants et
pour avoir que moi même réaliser une
commune nouvelle en 2016 je dois dire
quand même en particulier à notre
collègue chanopin combien je suis épaté
par sa réalisation qui paraît quand même
assez exceptionnel je pense qu'on
pourrait et on devrait emmener beaucoup
de nos élus municipaux visitez votre
territoire je pense que ce serait
sûrement intéressant mais je vais
reprendre mon mon tropisme financier que
me reproche souvent madame la Présidente
effectivement on est on a évoqué
la manière de ne pas désinciter les gens
et je voudrais rejoindre notre ami
Bernard à Goyer dans dans sa
dans son approche de distinguer les
petites comme une nouvelle des grandes
communes nouvelles parce que je pense
qu'effectivement les les villes
importantes qui se lancent dans des
communes nouvelles peuvent trouver des
en fait des économies d'échelle et des
projets rien que par la masse critique
qu'il constitue mais souvent les petites
communes ils se lancent dans des
communes nouvelles
ont sont très sensibles à l'évolution
des dotations parce que ça représente
une somme très importante par rapport à
leurs ressources globales alors est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que pour avoir
justement participé aux discussions
qu'on a eu l'an dernier à la loi de
finances où on s'est heurté quand même à
la à la fois la DGCL et à Bercy qui nous
disait si jamais vous vous lancez dans
le maintien des avantages de manière
éternelle vous allez
casser la baraque dans la mesure où si
disons certaines grandes communes
optimisent un petit peu le système et
elles vont faire éclater les choses et
alors ne pourrait-on pas pour être
direct
essayer de de distinguer justement les
petites des grandes communes et dire par
exemple mais à partir de quel seuil on
maintient les avantages définitivement
c'est à dire je pense peut-être 9000
habitants quelque chose comme ça mais ne
pas aller alors je sais que dès qu'on
parle de seuil chacun va un peu moi je
verrai assez bien cette je suis
dans le département où les communes sont
très petites alors sûrement que j'ai
je suis mais enfin voilà c'est un peu
une question comme comment vous
sentiriez ça est-ce que ça vous
paraîtrait quelque chose d'intéressant
ou deux pour ceux qui sont très
stimulantes donc je propose voilà vous
organiser votre réponse et ensuite nous
avons
Lucien sanctionne qui qui souhaite
intervenir Cédric Vial et Patricia
schillingy voilà donc je ne sais pas qui
veut répondre on va faire une réponse
on va faire une réponse conjointe qu'on
aime la présidente si vous voulez bien
croiser d'abord la question de la taille
la taille elle est toujours critique
quelle que soit la taille et tout n'est
pas dans la taille donc c'est sûr que on
voit bien et je crois que c'était
l'esprit du législateur à l'époque
autour de Jacques Pélissard que la façon
dont c'est rédigé ça doit être un outil
au service d'une volonté locale de faire
cause commune sur un territoire qui a du
sens
et ça ne doit pas me semble-t-il être
fait uniquement parce qu'on s'entend
bien avec son voisin ou être fait
uniquement parce que il y a une carotte
financière
donc c'est bien la question du projet et
de la vision que l'on a de son
territoire dans la tectonique des
plaques à l'époque de la loi neutre de
quelle place on va prendre dans cette
nouvelle géographie des territoires qui
se dessine et il faut insister là-dessus
alors c'est sûr on en a pas connaissance
de beaucoup mais qui peut y avoir des
risques de retour en arrière parce que
on n'a pas participé à l'élaboration du
projet et qu'on ne l'a pas compris
après il y a un salon de garantie me
semble-t-il qu'il faut apporter par la
gouvernance de la commune nouvelle si la
commune nouvelle est gouvernée par la
juxtaposition des communes déléguées qui
la composent
il y a un risque dislocation
si au contraire on fait en sorte et
donner l'expérience qui est la nôtre et
elle est reprise par bien des communes
nouvelles donc notamment de taille au
nombre plus importants de communes
déléguées
où on confie à chacun des mers délégués
une fonction d'adjoint
je vais vous ajouter obligatoirement mon
collègue qui voulait pas être trop de
responsabilités qui ne voulait être que
merder j'ai refusé pourquoi parce que
chaque mer délégué est en adjoint à
l'obligation de faire cause commune dans
la mission qui est la sienne et donc est
obligé d'être en solidarité avec ses
collègues et ne peut pas jouer perso
c'est quand même un sujet qui nous
permet de garantir à la fois la cohésion
du groupe d'une part et aussi de
consolider au fur et à mesure du temps
qui passe et des projets qui aboutissent
ce qui pose malgré tout et vous serez
amené j'imagine à bien travailler
là-dessus la question du statut du maire
délégué que nous considérons pour tous
ceux qui pensent qu'il faut maintenir
les communes déléguées comme
effectivement un élu indispensable
incarnant la proximité incarnant
l'histoire étant le relais du parc des
concitoyens au regard de la commune
nouvelle et c'est d'autant plus
important que repérer mettent et grand
il n'empêche que
la Loi ne doit pas lui permettre
d'avoir une tentation de Sécession
alors que tout de suite c'est possible
si d'aventure je prends un exemple
il fallait que j'ai des difficultés
c'est que le maire quand il démissionne
tous les adjoints sont démissionnés et
puis on recommence là-bas ça va pas etc
si je fais cela les mers délégués sont
toujours en poste c'est un sujet
donc il y a un moment il faut qu'il y
ait effectivement une unité de
commandement et les mers délégués
doivent bien sûr ils ont
les responsabilités
judiciaire que l'État lui a confié etc
ok mais il n'empêche que il faut
garantir cela en tout cas il faut pas
que la loi permette donc il faut me
semble-t-il réfléchir à ça deuxième
point mais je veux pas abuser sur le
temps si en matière d'urbanisme on a une
expérience qu'on avait fait avant la
commune nouvelle un PLU non pas
intercommunal mais partagé à 11 communes
on a fait 11 pays tous ensemble avec un
même bureau d'études à même un cabinet
avec les groupes de travail transverses
on a eu cette expérience là autant vous
dire que j'étais pas très favorable au
fait que quand on est rentré dans
l'interco qu'ils avaient choisi le PLU
intercommunal
à 50 communes sans secteurs enfin vous
imaginez dans quel bazar on peut pour se
trouver
mais par contre me semble-t-il le
document la planification de l'urbanisme
c'est une vraie souveraineté de la
commune et
la loi et ces rues qui a
qui a confié à l'intercool le soin de
les réaliser c'est là encore une perte
de pouvoir de la commune nous sommes
nous ardons défenseurs du fait communal
de la commune et la commune nouvelle
c'est ce qui me semble-t-il est en
capacité d'affirmer davantage de pouvoir
des communes plutôt que de se les voir
noyer dans des intercos de plus en plus
grandes
merci beaucoup Philippe peut-être un mot
et je rappelle nous avons ensuite votre
4 demandes de parole alors je reviens
pas sur le pays je suis désolé d'être
désagréable puisque nous avons fait un
PLU à l'échelle de la commune Nivelle
donc il y a pas de sujet des choses
s'organisent et on peut avoir des des
communes de différents de différents
rangs qui ont des droits à construire
plus importants sur l'aspect financier
je vais vous donner un exemple je
connais en Mayenne une commune nouvelle
qui fonctionne très bien tellement bien
que les communes voisines avoisinantes
veulent venir avec elle
la commune en question fait un peu plus
de 9000 habitants
et le maire et la commune nouvelle en
question refuse l'extension parce que
elle franchirait le seuil des 10000 et
donc elle va elle perdrait quand on fait
une commune nouvelle la carotte
financière on sait pas ça qui nous
motive c'est le service apporté à nos
habitants parce qu'on travaille sur un
bassin de vie une commune nouvelle qui
est construite ailleurs que sur un
bassin de vie ça fonctionne pas parce
que les habitants doivent avoir
l'habitude de se rencontrer et donc
l'aspect financier on nous dit les
communes nouvelles ont des avantages
attendez
j'ai autant de patrimoine sur Beaujeu en
Anjou que l'agglomération danger vous
trouvez que c'est un avantage c'est une
charge donc j'assume cette charge on
assume cette charge on a des églises on
a 15 églises au lieu de les abattes on
les réhabilite et on les entretient
est-ce que c'est une avantage non c'est
une charge qu'on comporte les nos
collèges nos écoles donc les communes
nouvelles elles ont de par leur
constitution des charges qui sont des
charges qu'on trouve généralement dans
les agglomérations quand on est sur des
communes importantes il faut pas que la
notion de seuil décourage les communes
de se regrouper nous on plaide à la MF
parce que il s'agit pas de prendre
l'argent des autres
c'est aujourd'hui on a des situations où
on touche moins de dotation moins de
subventions parce qu'on a en commun une
nouvelle on veut simplement notre dû et
on veut simplement qu'on nous attribue à
minima les dotations auxquelles nous
avions droit par le passé la DGF de la
commune de Baugé en Anjou à la DSR des
SR elle n'a jamais évolué depuis 2012
alors grâce à la réforme et à
l'adaptation c'est la loi de finance
voulue par le Sénat aujourd'hui elle a
évolué mais moi ma DSR n'évoluait pas
sous prétexte que j'avais de la DSU mais
j'ai pas cherché à avoir de la DSU il
aurait fallu parce que je dépasse 10 000
habitants et je remplis les critères
j'ai pas cherché à faire ça c'est la
conséquence des la loi elle doit rester
générale à partir du moment où on
commence à vouloir la modifier parce que
effectivement elle permet d'avoir des
situations différentes on va pas s'en
sortir nous ce qu'on dit simplement
c'est faut tenir compte du fait communal
de la commune nouvelle parce que on a
des problématiques qui sont pas les
mêmes et avoir une périnisation ce qui
ralentit le le processus de constitution
des communes nouvelles aujourd'hui c'est
assez simple c'est l'insécurité
juridique et financière tous les ans au
moment où la loi de finance paraît on
regarde les maladies qu'est-ce qui se
passe cette fois-ci est-ce qu'on va
perdre moi on m'avait annoncé l'année
dernière j'avais perdre 450 000 euros
comme ça
comme ça et on fait on gère comment un
budget communal on veut simplement de la
sécurité et on veut pas plus que les
autres on veut ce qui nous était
attribué avant
Philippe ce point-là est très important
le Sénat a sauvé la vie pour un an de
beaucoup de communes nouvelles mais on a
un sujet puisqu'on a des communes sur un
seuil qui perdent de la DSR parce
qu'elles arrivent à 10000 mais elles ne
sont pas éligibles à déçus et je connais
un exemple de prêt d'une commune de 10
000 habitants qui a perdu qui aurait
perdu près de 600 000 euros si voilà
donc c'est un sujet président à collier
si vous voulez intervenir pour répondre
voilà et ensuite je passe la parole à
nos quatre collègues tout en surveillant
monsieur le Président
merci
je nourris une petite réserve sur le
dissuin Go qui était effectué entre les
dotations
et leur évolution entre les communes de
d'un faible nombre d'habitants et les
communes plus importantes en effet il
quand même un équilibre qui doit être
respecté au titre de l'égalité entre les
contribuables qui sont autre que des
citoyens d'une part et d'autre part
la charge financière qui pèse sur les
grandes collectivités et qui ne cesse
d'être plus aiguë au fur et à mesure que
l'État restreint les dotations d'une
part et les capacités de lever la peau
par les collectivités locales soulèvent
un vrai problème de ressources de
fiscalité pour ces grandes collectivités
et leur attractivité en termes
économique or c'est souvent dans ces
grandes collectivités que se situe les
plus grandes entreprises bref le coeur
de
l'économie
nationale et par conséquent je pense que
ce point est un point qui ne doit pas
[Musique]
suscité des problèmes et et il y a je
crois dans l'esprit de la loi qui a
permis ces fusions la volonté de pouvoir
faire bénéficier les contribuables
davantage qui sont mutualisés au plan
national pour les grandes collectivités
qui franchissent ce pas et et ces
grandes collectivités ont une marge
d'économies parce qu'il est vrai qu'il y
a redondance des services et qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'espace d'économies
autant dans les petites collectivités en
termes de nombre d'habitants même si
elles sont étendues il n'y a strictement
aucune marge d'économie parce qu'elles
sont déjà à l'os il y a dans les les
agglomérations qui regroupent beaucoup
de communes il y a des redondances de
service qui peuvent être mis en commun
et c'est ce point que j'ai voulu
souligner tout à l'heure qui devait
faire l'objet d'une étude d'impact plus
précise mais d'un plan de mise en commun
et donc d'un suivi d'une évaluation des
résultats en termes de maintien bien
entendu ou d'amélioration du service
public mais du meilleur efficient en
termes financier de ce service public je
prends juste l'exemple des surfaces
d'administratives des surfaces publics
il est évident qu'il y a des marges
d'économie et que les collectivités ne
peuvent indéfiniment augmenter leur
patrimoine immobilier et fonciers et
qu'elles doivent aboutir soit des
locations soit à des bouts
amphithéotique soit des ventes d'une
partie de ce patrimoine immobilier et
foncier de manière à ce que la charge
qui pèse sur le contribuable soit infini
allégé la dépense publique ne peut pas
même au niveau des collectivités locales
croître indéfiniment et il revient à
tous les élus que que j'ai été que vous
êtes de d'être attentif à cette
évolution qui fait que la France a une
dépense publique qui est plus élevée que
tous les autres pays comparables aux
nôtres et que même si nos collectivités
sont bien gérées il y a quand même une
évolution à la hausse globale qui ne
peut pas être
ignoré
coucou monsieur le Président donc il
nous reste 10 minutes pardon pour
les questions de nos cinq collègues si
toutefois les réponses ne sont pas vous
n'avez pas le temps de vous exprimer moi
je vous invite à compléter par écrit les
réponses
aux questions de nos collègues à qui je
demande d'ores et déjà extrêmement
d'indulgence donc Lucien stationne
Cédric Vial Patricia Schillinger Corinne
Ferret voilà Lucien je t'en prie merci
madame la Présidente d'abord je
souhaitais m'excuser parce que ma
collègue silure Berne avait une
commission à la culture imprévue et
exceptionnelle et donc on est arrivé un
peu en retard tout ça pour dire que
j'aurais aimé entendre vos témoignages
parce que pour j'ai fait le tour de la
table on est deux du Sud
parmi le président le vice-président qui
est du Sud aussi voilà pas le même et je
trouve que moi je vous écoute avec
fascination parce que chez nous sauf
chez toi peut-être mais ça n'existe
absolument pas
ça n'existe absolument pas c'est à dire
que
la question des fusions de communes dans
le sud de la France et quelque chose qui
est méconnu complètement qui ne
fonctionne pas et d'ailleurs quand je
vous entends c'est effectivement une
espèce de vraie alternative par rapport
à dualité commune intercommunalité bon
et d'ailleurs c'est le souci que nous
avons sur place de comment fonctionne
sur tous les aspects et alors moi je
l'appelle la présidente Elvis président
peut-être que ça nécessiterait qu'on
regarde mieux ce qui se passe dans le
sud quelle est la résistance sur cette
parce que j'ai même envisagé d'aller
rendre visite à des collègues qui ont
procédé voilà pour pour voir de quoi il
retourne quoi parce que vraiment voilà
donc c'est une interrogation et
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs de vos témoignages et
permettez-moi aussi un salut amical tout
particulier mes amis qui savoyarde à
notre collègue Bernard racouillé
moi j'ai une question très courte sur la
question de la gouvernance vous en avez
parlé un peu monsieur tout à l'heure
avec deux types de questions la première
c'est sur le nombre de conseillers
municipaux puisqu'il y a une période
d'intégration on réuni tout le monde
puis après on diminue
jusqu'à une période de stabilisation
quel est votre vision sur le nombre
d'élus infini est-ce que l'objectif
c'est de rentrer sur le droit commun
[Musique]
et la question ça légitimité
parce que
faut-il qu'il soit le maire délégué
auprès de la commune déléguée
c'est derrière
c'est un comme un adjoint qui soit nommé
par qui règlerait la question de poser
tout à l'heure et
il retente le maire pour faire les
habitants il faut qu'ils reprennent les
habitants
merci Cédric Patricia merci madame la
Présidente
avec qui nous retournerons en Normandie
alors
une commune nouvelle où c'était pas très
facile qui a fait quand même la une des
journaux c'est la commune nouvelle de
kaysersber vignoble où il y avait
enrichtol juste pour vous dire de la
nouvelle la mère qui était élu
elle a vraiment elle me fait remonter
régulièrement parce que je siège à la
Commission de la DETR qu'elle a perdu
énormément Laure de la fusion des trois
communes je voulais savoir si vous vous
aviez aussi cette problématique là et
cela freinait vraiment dans les
investissements parce que c'est une
perte importante
merci pour la concision chers Corinne
oui merci Madame la président j'avais
une question qui portait plus sur le
gouvernance vous avez évoqué cette
question qui vient d'en parler un peu
dans le Calvados nous avons été un des
départements où il y avait dans un
premier temps très peu de commune
nouvelle et puis vraiment il y a une
dynamique qui se crée aujourd'hui on a
44 comme une nouvelle avec des
disparités Sonia l'a évoqué dans la dans
la taille c'est aussi le question le
sujet que vous aviez évoqué on a des
communes nouvelles à deux ou trois
communes et puis on a des communes
nouvelles qui regroupent 22 communes
mais seulement un tout petit peu plus de
6000 habitants d'autres une autre
commune nouvelle qui en regroupe huit
communes qui atteint la 17000 habitants
donc on est même sur des territoires on
arrive presque à un cinquième du
Calvados sur certains territoires et des
disparités comme tu veux que aussi ou
des zones entières du département sont
absolument pas impliqués ou en tout cas
engagé dans cette dynamique et ma
question sur le gouvernance portait sur
le rôle du du maire délégué dans
beaucoup de communes nouvelles le maire
de la commune nouvelle et le maire de
légué de la commune principale pour dire
ça n'est pas le cas dans toutes les
communes et je souhaitais avoir votre
avis comment vous qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cela est-ce que vous pensez
que il faudrait que systématiquement le
maire de la commune nouvelle ne soit pas
le maire délégué de la commune centre et
on a dans notre actualité récente chers
Sonia une évolution justement sur une de
ces communes nouvelles où le maire de la
commune nouvelle vient de démissionner
de son rôle de mère délégué de la
commune principale est-ce la bonne
méthode ou vos expériences montrent que
peut-être pardon si vous permet la
parole à Eric qui voulait qui devra
excusez-moi mais il a vraiment une
contrainte il devra nous quitter à 10h30
donc j'aurai le remercier pour sa
sobriété de parole inversement
proportionnel à la mienne merci pas du
tout simplement vous donner deux
chiffres parce qu'on a pas de pu donner
tous les chiffres et ça répond à
indirectement à la question de cédrivial
dans la dans le questionnaire il y a 60%
des mers qui sont pour l'alignement du
statut de mer délégué sur celui
d'adjoint à compter du premier
renouvellement ça c'est le premier point
et surtout le deuxième point à compter
du deuxième renouvellement du conseil
municipal les majoritairement les mers
ont répondu à 75% qu'il souhaitait une
diminution du nombre des conseillers
municipaux voilà
juste un petit un petit mot sur la
gouvernance dans les conditions quand il
a fallu que je devienne maire de la
commune nouvelle j'ai surpris mes
collègues en disant j'ai une condition à
poser c'est que je ne veux plus être
mère du bourg parce qu'on ne peut pas
être davantage mère de l'un que de
l'autre pour être mère de tous il faut
être au dessus premier point et ça
renvoie la question des maires délégués
effectivement ils sont les représentants
du maire dans les communes déléguées et
bien sûr qu'ils sont à l'interface mais
enfin c'est pas le la circonscription
électorale c'est toute la commune c'est
pas par commune déléguée ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième élément sur le
nombre de conseillers c'est tout à fait
essentiel à la MF on travaille avec
l'ensemble des collègues pour essayer de
trouver les situations tout à l'heure on
vous parlait de la taille
c'est le nombre d'habitants qui pour
l'instant détermine les conseils il nous
semble que dès lors que les communes
déléguées sont maintenues il faut aller
vers un statut particulier de la commune
nouvelle la Constitution le permet et
que du coup les conseils municipaux
soient composés d'un nombre de
conseillers qui représentent les
habitants plus
autant de conseillers qu'il y a comme
une nouvelle à minima parce que tous
nous ont dit si c'est le droit commun
parfois c'est pas assez et si il y a
trop de communes et peu d'habitants et
parfois c'est trop donc on a il faut et
il faut vraiment on est prêt à
travailler avec la délégation même la
présidente pour faire tout dissimulation
nécessaire avec l'échantillon que nous
avons en la matière
la présidente très rapidement aussi sur
les deux sujets évoqués il y a une
évolution en 2012 ceux qui sont devenus
maire délégués c'était les mers
d'origine des communistes
et là ils étaient pas envisageable de de
les révoquer aujourd'hui les maires
délégués n'ont jamais été maire
il représente le maire de la commune
nouvelle sur la commune déléguée il faut
garder à mon avis les communes déléguées
après faut-il avoir un maire délégué
fléché comme une déléguée la question
peut se poser mais en tout cas la
fonction de merde déléguée doit évoluer
parce que on évolue dans le temps alors
sur le nombre de conseillers bouger en
Anjou en 2013 le canton c'était
pratiquement 200 conseillers en 2026 on
nous propose 35 conseillers pour un
territoire qui n'a pas diminué en
superficie et qui a vu son nombre
d'habitants augmenté donc il est évident
qu'on peut pas travailler comme ça si on
garde les communes déléguées il faut un
maire délégué il faut donc que ce merder
là ou un adjoint délégué puisse rentrer
dans le calcul des effectifs la
proposition que cela MF sur ce point il
faut l'enjeu d'une commune nouvelle
c'est la proximité si vous n'avez pas un
maire ou un élu à proximité de parole ou
d'échanges avec les habitants ça
fonctionne pas
et là les gens se disent la commune
nouvelle bah je vois plus personne et
deuxièmement sur les aspect financier je
reviens là-dessus c'est un peu mon
cheval le bataille c'est vrai
aujourd'hui dans les commissions je
préside je composais de la Commission de
etter du département de Maine-et-Loire
Monsieur le Préfet nous dit où tous les
préfets nous ont dit un dossier par
commune
avant il y avait 15 communes déléguées
chacun déposé son petit dossier
aujourd'hui on a un gros dossier pour
les 15 communes donc ça c'est pas
tenable non plus encore une fois l'État
doit comprendre que la commune nouvelle
c'est quelque chose qui peut simplifier
l'action publique sur le territoire et
c'est un relais on existerait pas dans
des intercommunalités aujourd'hui à 50
60 communes s'il y avait pas de communes
nouvelles parce que la commune nouvelle
permet de rationaliser et d'organiser le
fait intercommunal donc il faut une
spécificité il faut tenir compte des
financements il faut arrêter dans notre
pays de sanctionner ceux qui font des
efforts c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
merci merci
beaucoup pour la clarté la pertinence et
l'intérêt de vos interventions et
surtout merci pour nous permettre de
tenir le temps chers collègues on aura
l'occasion de reparler de tout ça parce
que c'est un je crois un travail
extrêmement intéressant il est heureux
que nous le partageons ensemble au sein
de de la délégation et je voudrais juste
rappeler quelque chose qui me paraît
très fort au travers de ce que vous avez
dit c'est-à-dire la commune nouvelle est
une entreprise pour le futur du
territoire mais les lois peuvent être et
Dieu sait si au final sont bien faites
vous l'avez dit vous-même toujours
excellente elles sont mises en oeuvre
par des hommes et des femmes qui ont une
histoire particulière avec leur
territoire et parfois entre eux et qu'à
chaque fois on voit bien qu'il y a une
dimension humaine et particulière qui
fait que la gouvernance est un exercice
on va dire humain et que la loi ne
pourra jamais figée parce que la commune
nouvelle est vraiment une initiative
portée par les élus locaux c'est pour ça
qu'elle réussit il faut pas non plus
qu'on enferme la gouvernance même si on
doit permettre des choses en tout cas
1000 merci et vous savez combien nous
continuons nos travaux avec un temps
cité sur le sujet et je vais à nouveau
remercier la MF pour se dialogue très
nourrique que nous avons et l'ensemble
des collègues pour cette démarche
transpartisanale je vous assure et je
tiens à le dire à remercier nos
collègues sur ce sujet parce que nous
sommes très attachés aux libertés
locales n'ont pas pour le plaisir d'être
des rebelles mais parce que nous pensons
que c'est la liberté locale qui permet
aux élus d'assumer leur responsabilité
l'idée d'inventer des possibles qui
marchent beaucoup mieux
merci voilà et nous allons donc monsieur
le ministre Guerini est arrivé
voilà merci beaucoup
Eric donc j'invite les collègues
Jérôme Durin Catherine difolco Cédric
Vial à me rejoindre puisque nous allons
parler attractivité de la fonction
territoriale
je